hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game uh also from round three
of this year's Sharjah Masters uh we
have a game between Grand Master
Platinum galparin and The Grandmaster
sun and sugirov if you guys remember
Simon sugar of the old Magnus Carlsen
Nemesis uh he defeated him twice once in
2010 uh the other time in 2020. okay
2020 was uh an online event and it was a
rap uh Blitz game I believe uh but in
2010 he defeated him in a classical game
and it is to this day considered one of
Magnus carlsen's greatest defeats if you
haven't seen it I have made a video on
it it's a beautiful game uh will be the
first link in the description below so
check it out and also I will put the
second link the second game that he
played against Magnus and for those of
you who haven't heard in my previous
video uh the game that you we were all
waiting for
um a world champion juvenile versus
pragnalanda ended in a draw it was a
fairly uneventful game so I decided not
to show it but
um yeah pretty much every game ended in
a draw and round three these are just
the top 10 boards so you can see that
all of them were drawn so I had to
search deeper to find this one but you
know the the more the the lower you go
the the more interesting the games
become it's usually how it works uh so
let's check it out it's a wonderful game
the slav defense and you will see how
how dangerous it can be uh for both
sides so let's check it out a platon has
the white pieces and he opens with uh uh
Pawn to D4 we have Ponta d5c4 going for
the Queen's Gambit and now C6 declining
it with the slot defense we have Pawn to
E3 now usually you will see Knight to F3
or Knight the C3 or even C captures on
D5 Ponte E3 is the fourth most popular
uh Choice here and it's not played that
often so okay Knight to F6 uh Knight's
the C3 we have E6 now uh and uh here
just Knight to F3 we have Knight beta D7
uh the main level of the semi-slav and
queen to C2 this is the Schultz
variation of the semi-slav uh Bishop to
D6 and now bash of the D3 so just
continuing development we have castles
castles and the D captures on C4 with
Bishop captures and now Pawn to A6 we
have Pawn to A3 preparing B4 and usually
uh or something that you might even
expect even if this hasn't been played
you would you would expect something
like B5 Bishop to B7 Rook to C8 and only
then something like C5 and it's pretty
much always the exact same set of the
black uses uh the the move order can
differentiate a bit but here we have
pawned the C5 right away uh challenging
the center uh D captures and C5 bit of
an unprincipled move as it's capturing
away from the center you would also
maybe consider a rook to D1 here but it
does allow Pawn to B4 to be played with
Tempo and then maybe the bishop can come
to this long diagonal so it it you know
it's a bit of a trade-off but okay we
have Pawn to B4 chasing away the bishop
Bishop back to E7 and now uh the
position has been reached before a few
times even in top tier games for example
um alexand
but in all of those instances uh it is
white who lost these positions so white
has never won this position there are a
couple of games that ended in a draw and
uh the the talk to your game sended by
black winning and uh in those games uh
Bishop the B2 was played also Knights
the D4 is a known move but here we have
Bishop back to D3 and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how the game continues
Pawn to B5 and okay of course you want
the bishop on this long diagonal uh we
have Pawn to E4 and this is the
beautiful moment of the game that I
think that we should really
uh consider for a moment because here
you might uh think okay I just played B5
I'm just going to continue with my
natural development Bishop to B7 and
Rook to C8 but here uh salmon did not
play this he played Bishop to D6 and
it's the correct decision uh I I will
just show why and uh the reason is after
Bishop to B7 then white can play E5 he
played Bishop to D6 in the line that
we've shown to stop this and it seems
like it's not that big of a deal okay it
opens up this diagonal but it also gives
black some ideas Bishop captures an F3
what happens now okay e captures an F6
Bishop captures on F6 and now we have to
play G captures and F3 so it seems like
okay you've messed up white spawn
structure in front of the king why not
play this well uh black will also come
under attack the H7 Pawn is hanging the
king will come to H1 The Rook can come
to G1 but also some very forced lines
are possible here like Rook the C8
pulling pressure on the Knight the
bishop to beat you defending and now
Bishop to E5 preparing to bring the
queen into the game but now look at the
spawn to F4 but now Queen to H4 not
going for Glory it's basically offering
a draw Queen to G for Fall by Queen to
F3 will be a Perpetual draw which black
can accept by capturing sorry white can
accept by capturing an E5 or you decline
it with Bishop captures on H7 now Queen
captures and H7 is bad because you also
become the bishop in the end so King to
h8 Bishop to E4 and now Queen captures
an F4 going for checkmate here but
there's Rook after E1 I mean this line
is so so weird Queen captures an H2
check King to F1 you're not worried
about anything the bishop covers the H1
square but now look at this bishop
captures and C3 Bishop captures and
queen H3 check nicely connecting with
the bishop and C3 King to E2 beautiful
move threatening Rook to H1 to win the
black queen and now you will see Rook
captures in C3 Queen captures on C3
white gives up the queen king captures
and Rook to H1 uh will force a Perpetual
now with Bishop to H7 check or you can
even be super funny about it you can
even sacrifice a just for good fun and
then you know force a draw with the
other Rogue Bishop to H7 check and now
you just force a draw you don't really
care so uh that's the reason why after
E4 Bishop to B7 that is not the precise
move order Bishop to D6 the move that
tsugiro played is the correct way to
play and now E5 is impossible unless
white wants to sacrifice it just open up
this diagonal but for the moment it
doesn't really make all that much sense
so Bishop to G5 was played Bishop to B7
and now Queen to E2 adding another
Defender here but also just getting uh
the queen away from the c5c to square
with Queen to B8 now uh sanon puts his
uh Queen and Bishop on this diagonal and
look at that Bishop pair now it is most
certainly fully operational we have H3
H6 uh chasing away the bishop Bishop to
E3 and now Knight to E5 putting pressure
on the light Square Bishop so Rook 8 to
D1 uh sorry uh Rook a to D1 and now uh
we have Rook the C8 getting the other
Rook into the game the Knight is
undefended here and now Knight captures
on E5 Bishop captures and Knight the B1
now if you can get your knight into the
game Let's unite the D2 Knight to F3
should be okay but uh the E4 Pawn is
hanging but is it really hanging because
you know that at the end of the line
once everything gets uh traded then
Bishop captures and H6 is coming opening
up up a discovery on that whatever will
be an E4 but here Simon says that it's
perfectly fine and that it is in fact
great for black so Bishop characters on
e4 Bishop captures Knight captures and
Bishop captures on H6 now threatening
Queen captures night here but just
Knight back to F6 now you don't have
Queen to G4 and also the bishop is
hanging so how do you continue here well
the best way would be to call it a day
the adventure is over you go back and
the game continues maybe you can even
put a bishop on C5 and have a great
position but here Pawn the F4 was played
uh trying to get captures and captures
but they're basically just chasing the
black Bishop back but this gives black a
whole lot of new options because now
both of these diagonals are open and
that can be very very scary uh for white
and I've seen this happen in many many
lines of the semi-slav if you guys
remember there's even a game I played in
the in the Croatian League where my
opponent played Ponte F4 I also had a
similar setup and I was able to to check
it and meet him very quickly so Bishop
the C7 was played with Bishop to G5 now
threatening to mess up a black spawn
structure but just Knight the D5 and now
already you're having some problems here
with the F Pawn uh it's being attacked
three times and what you should do here
and it's not an easy move to find you
should play King H1 but it seems like
this is too difficult a move to find
point now is that you cannot capture an
F4 black has to find some different way
of how to play this and then F5 is
coming uh problem is if you play Bishop
captures on F4 then just Rook captures
on D5 you remove the defender of the
bishop it's that simple and if Knight
captures an F4 then Queen F3 and that
Knight will remain there for a very very
long time even if E5 you can play
something like Knights the C3 and then
if Rook to f8 because you have to defend
that F Pawn then even Rook to D7 and all
of a sudden it's not black who's
attacking in this game but okay after
Knight the D5 we have Pawn to F5 and
this uh well this really ruins the game
uh this really ruins the game because
now there's a very uh a particular set
of moves that you can uh you can find in
order to gain great Advantage here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
spot this the the series of moves while
I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop to
B6 with check indeed by playing F5 the
bishop and G5 is undefended and the
queen is now coming to G3 and yes then
the bishop is coming back to C7 so
that's why it's really really dangerous
to open up those diagonals King H1 Queen
to G3 now attacking the bishop and now
we have Bishop back to C1 here uh with
Queen G4 you are still fighting it's not
going to be easy but you're still
fighting let's say captures captures
Rook the C4 you will lose the G4 pawn
and then uh well you you can hope to
survive maybe but after Bishop to C1 uh
the game is now definitely over uh so
feel free to pause the video I'm just
kidding I already told you what the
winning move is uh but uh Bishop to B6
check was the winning move because now
you've basically switched positions you
don't have a Queen Bishop battery you
have a bishop Queen battery now just
Bishop back to C7 and there's no
defending this Checkmate is coming or
you can start running away with the King
which is what Platinum did King to G1
was played Queen to age to check with
King to F2 now comes Bishop the B6 check
and you don't have a move if King T1
didn't just Queen to G3 check if Rook F2
just captures you bringing a rook turn
at the E8 it's game over so in the game
after Bishop to B6 check King the F3 was
played but now uh for real feel free to
pause the video and to win the game for
black once and for all while I give you
a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the only thing standing in our way of
delivering Queen to F for checkmate is
the bishop and C1 so makes it you know
pretty self-explanatory congratulations
to everyone as I have no doubt that
everyone found this Rook captures on C1
and he was in this position on move 31
that platon galperian resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here now you just lost material and
there is no defense uh I mean you're
done material and if you act on that
then Queen to F4 will be Checkmate there
is no other way to play this and of
course that's why after work captures on
C1 he resigned there is no uh no good
way even if traceable captures on D5
okay you're first gonna deliver a check
and only after Queen captures capture
and D5 and now you're just up a full
Rook of course you are completely
winning uh so yeah uh beautiful
beautiful game and I think it can all uh
you know be brought down to this moment
where white played E4 which is a fine
move uh but yeah if you just continue
with something that feels normal like
Bishop to B7 Rook to C8 and you know
that those pieces belong on those
squares if you are a semi-slav player uh
it's just that Bishop to D6 in this
particular line is slightly more precise
and allows black to even play for a win
not just allow white to force some sort
of uh some sort of a draw uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by silence I would like
to thank David Kimura Petra marinov AMD
recent Enthusiast group golfsoftware.com
and Paul hinemoon for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day